[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o court
no dia em que recebi o convite oficial
para aqui hoje falar convosco em um
conselho do mercado e fazer um concelho
com uma aluna minha tinha desafiado uma
menina chamada energia também é
guitarrista tinha desafiado fazemos um
conselho de posição totalmente livre
como jazz nós podemos improvisar uma
premissa qual era uma canção tema
ou então podemos improvisar forma
totalmente livre vamos criando nosso
enredo musical em tempo real - compondo
em tempo real
ela região sindipi nós corpus aceito o
desafio era um bairro lisboa com dois
pisos que superior 1 que o barulho fase
do piso inferior uma casa onde aconteceu
o concerto
temos lá tudo muito bom fomos muito bem
recebidos lá pra baixo pra cá vem
montando nosso trials nosso teste de som
diz leandro temos um ótimo jantar lá
achamos aos poucos e poucos com suas que
é pública e que hora do concerto
sentadas que começaram há quatro meses
antes de começar o quadro
achei por bem contextualizadas pessoas
aqui que seria queria passar ali disse
que iríamos fazer projeção somente livro
nem não chegue exatamente o que
aconteceu
é importante que as pessoas tenham o
espírito aberto tudo pode acontecer
também disse que este espaço entre o
palco eo público tudo que aconteceu
neste passeio influenciar músicos
passasse naquele momento e já as pessoas
boa viagem e se necessário para as
pessoas percebam empolgados com o que se
ia passar ali no preciso momento em que
começamos o quadro nossa primeira nota
no andar de cima com um green uma
pequena discussão alguma coisa não
estava bem mais tarde percebemos que
emicida polícia chegar aqui no qual
havia uma ação judicial contra o bar
inspiram àquela hora e que o qual o
único dia frio dono um dia especial em
que os primeiros vídeos do concerto que
o burburinho começou assim acabou numa
do curso aos gritos e que há vários
meses a registar o dono evitar chama
edifícios temeu-se não podem fazer isso
chamam loucura só nós lá em baixo e
ouvimos e quilo e que nós fizemos nunca
paramos de tocar aqui eu fui moto com a
nossa presença aqui na verdade nos
inspiração para criarmos no momento uma
banda sonora daquela loucura
eu era uma discussão absolutamente época
havia uma tensão incrível no carro nós
já subimos mais iriam de mandar parar
nossas pessoas iam fugir todas mas que
foi tudo bem na verdade foi histórico
foi épico toda a gente define se é que o
momento incrível que os primeiros 20
minutos foram espetaculares por cima
estavam com a condição que estavam em
cima do meu lado foi isso na verdade
logo no dia em que recebi este convite
uma história feita pelo estrago que a
improvisação e posição é isto é criar no
momento em tempo real sem planos
terminados e muitas vezes acho que todos
nós já passamos por situações de
improviso na vida nós no dia a dia as
situações que nos obrigam a improvisar
nós não temos outras cantoras não
improvisar e se tivermos este gosto de
cuidar de improvisar também vamos
procurar situações que sejam precisão em
províncias e quando nós temos essa
disponibilidade e práticas incluem
propuseram também não fui olhar e
disputar este super player que o poder
de improviso e super poder que nos
permite às situações mais adversas e
mais inusitadas fazermos algo no morava
e como isso acontece na música
quando nós falamos em improvisação
musical muitas vezes fazemos um paralelo
com a linguagem do futebol
porque a música é também uma forma de
comunicar os pássaros e no fundo o que
acontece entre os músicos no palco uma
conversa musical e música é música é
possível provocar sensações sem dizer
uma única palavra e vou dar um exemplo
se este quadro esta corda
[Música]
se calhar imagina se um dia bonito sol
como está hoje com pessoas que gostam no
sítio quando gostam está no entanto se
usar apenas uma nota neste corte que o
acordo melhor entre nós o vosso dia
passa a ser
[Música]
apenas uma nota passa a ser triste
melancólico se calhar algumas nuvens
se calhar alguma chuva simular uma nota
neste corpo no litoral diminuto o vosso
dia passa a ser
misterioso que ele era o traje está
prestes a acontecer
isso sem dizer uma única palavra só terá
uma palheta jornadas do fim é esse lugar
algo este chão como todos os estilos
musicais mas nélson santos exatamente da
mesma forma porque a linguagem da música
é uma linguagem universal
mas é como se os títulos fossem frente
de elétrons grandes estoques em maneiras
de falar dessa linguagem universal
se o lugar no alguns dos sons e ficaram
num universo pop esperar que o vem desta
forma
[Música]
se fosse um universo rock 12 missões 11
ministros da corte
o som desta forma foram descobriu a
música popular brasileira bossa nova que
criaram mesmo recorte o fim da conversa
desta forma e chegamos hoje as que o
estilo musical que o macho por ai mas
falo no meu dia-a-dia olímpico é uma
coisa distinta
[Música]
o carrão preço eram apenas no ar muitas
muitas variantes nesta linguagem
universal que é a música então como
fazemos isso de profissão precisamos
realmente de que isto acontece
como eu disse no início podemos ter uma
premissa marcação e vou dar um exemplo o
ganês a corte estava quieto claro vou
gravar aqui que ela vai conhecer esta no
dia 7 a 0 nesta canção realmente vocês
conhecem os anúncios de august em que as
pessoas estão com uma colher na boca
assim ai ouvir esta letra diz reva time
reserva
esta canção chama tito de é um dos das
centenas milhares de sertanejos jazz do
cancioneiro americano composto chamado
harvey em berlim
nós fazemos nesta estrutura desta canção
do cabo no dia eu o letra quando a casa
de violeta
nós chegamos nessa estrutura neste caso
claro apenas um pequeno chefe da canção
que é muito mais longo do que a gestora
e fazemos variações décimo dia criamos
as nossas próprias músicas em uma
estrutura
vou dar um exemplo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
foi adiante
obrigado
então como é que nós trabalhamos para
isso não é necessário muita inspiração
divina no ativo
chegamos aqui o cara embora e e depois
acontece é preciso cada esse espírito
embora aí mas antes disso é preciso
trabalhar algumas ferramentas porque a
inscrição embora o facto tenha alguma
importância quando estamos a criar algo
é uma coisa que nós não controlamos
senhora cruzamos magnet criados no mesmo
no próprio no mesmo dia porém estava
inspirado manhã e à noite completamente
inspirado no plano de controlar isso
então há certas ferramentas como exigido
um ano pior dia todos mais desesperado
da minha vida e garantir uma prestação
boa então o que são essas ferramentas
primeiro turno
o vídeo o vídeo aqui o que permite
aprender a falar essa linguagem primeiro
do que ouvir tal como quando aprendemos
a falar ouvir os mestres esta linguagem
é repetir a imitar e aos poucos e poucos
é compreender e fala fluentemente
livremente esta linguagem
houve também aqui como permite quando
toco em grupo
a palavra-chave interação quantos
improvisar é importante ouvir os outros
e falar
musicalmente de acordo com o que está a
passar à nossa volta rígidos interagir e
ouvir também o nosso pensamento musical
que vai ficar dentro e que queremos
expressar isso leva outra ferramenta que
a técnica do instrumento
essa técnica não é de quase 100 mil
notas por segundo em 24 horas no sol e
as pessoas querem nos impor nada
isso também tem o seu lugar mas a
técnica do instrumento é simplesmente
concretizar este pensamento musical
arranjar uma forma natural de passar a
nossa mensagem nosso pensamento musical
através do nosso instrumento seja qual
for no caso da guitarra fazer com que
este instrumento seja uma extensão do
nosso corpo e para isso temos que passar
horas descobrir brincar explorar e é
fazer com que este instrumento seja uma
coisa é normal seja uma coisa natural
para nós que nós nos possamos de forma
clara e natural isto estas câmeras todas
trazem o palco onde tudo acontece
o palco é aqui que a sociedade sob a
adrenalina vem ao de cima é que as
pernas começam a tremer mas é aqui que
nós fomos a prova é que tentamos
determinar em casa aqui que realmente
acontece
e qual é o pior inimigo do improvisador
no palco expectativa porque improvisação
e composição em tempo real quantos
acompanham a música de 3 minutos após
passar três anos a compor uma música de
3 minutos posso andar para frente para
trás evitar lá tudo andar ali com muitas
indecisões no palco em posição 3012 cá
são três minutos de música com tudo o
que isso acarreta e por isso é
importante termos uma excelente relação
com o erro o erro em cima de muita coisa
contou que nós chegamos
o erro pode dizer que certas coisas que
nós estamos em casa comendo das
facilidades chegamos o palco sua opção e
não conseguimos executar mas não falta
quando isso acontece não podemos
bloquear temos que continuar e dar
continuidade ao nosso discurso musical e
aí é aí que o evanescence aí que o erro
nos mostra caminhos novos que nós não
sabíamos que existiam e aí que o euro
também nos mostra que nós às vezes
fazemos coisas que nem fazia ideia que
sabemos fazer
o erro é importante e por isso também
vai novamente uma uma expressão que é
uma grande cantora porque tem a sua
parte ao palco muitas vezes grande maria
joão
ela diz o que interessa aqui é aventura
da música
nós não temos equipe para entregar uma
coisa é perfeitinho numa caixinha linha
e bonitinha ao público não estamos aqui
para criar um momento para arriscar e
para quê ir levantar nos mostramos
alguma fragilidade mas vocês nunca tinha
uma coisa que é única e exclusiva deste
momento está a acontecer agora mas um
piloto aquela canção do tipo de que ela
pensa nos jogos agora e daqui a cinco
minutos
as versões podem ser bastante diferente
e nós gastamos dos cursos e se jogassem
conseguir continuava a ser a venda não
precisava tentar tirar o engenheiro
informático
mesmo seguindo desde que nasci no meu
quarto com medo de fracassar aqui no
palco eu nunca disse que seria a mesma
para cantar com ele com medo de
fracassar ou então não estaria aqui
falando com vocês hoje no youtube toada
falar
mais do que claro mas ainda assim claro
que esse quadro e que estava a dizer
finalizar a minha tholl ecoarem
provisório e como é que vou fazer isso
inclusive ao documento mas com uma
premissa a premissa não vê lá como de
vista em toda a falar sozinho sem o
reação clara mais novo ensaio de
perguntas nunca interagiu muito com você
de maneira que o evangelho interagir
convosco
foi este o pai de vocês cruzaram a sida
do coffee break
votei neste pachi e isso vai ser o
primeiro do improviso
vamos ver o que acontece
espero que tenha sido generosos mudança
o bobô está plantando na gestão de 15
minutos 20 cai então a mesma coisa que
disse é que o concerto que a polícia
chegou os prêmios que não chega agora
seja uma boa viagem
[Música]
ó
ae
[Música]
ei
o
[Música]
[Risadas]
reto